Érase una vez
una economía en la que vivíamos con crecimiento financiero y prosperidad.
Se le llamó la Gran Moderación,
la creencia equivocada de la mayoría de los economistas,
las autoridades y los bancos centrales
de que habíamos logrado un nuevo mundo
de incesante crecimiento y prosperidad.
Esto se creyó por el crecimiento robusto y estable del PIB,
por una inflación baja y controlada,
por bajo desempleo,
y por una volatilidad financiera controlada y baja.
Pero la gran recesión del 2007 y 2008,
la gran crisis, rompió esta ilusión.
Unas pérdidas de 100 mil millones de dólares en el sector financiero
llevó a detrimentos en cascada de
5 billones de dólares en el PIB mundial
y casi 30 billones de pérdidas
en los mercados de valores mundiales.
Como explicación de esta gran recesión
se dijo que era completamente sorprendente,
que vino de la nada,
que provenía de la ira de los dioses.
No hubo ninguna responsabilidad.
Por lo tanto, como respuesta a esto,
empezamos el Observatorio de Crisis Financieras.
Teníamos el objetivo de diagnosticar en tiempo real
las burbujas financieras
e identificar con anticipación su momento crítico.
¿Cuál es el sustento científico, de este observatorio financiero?
Desarrollamos la teoría llamada "dragones reyes".
Los dragones reyes representan eventos extremos
que son de una clase particular.
Son especiales, atípicos.
Se generan por mecanismos específicos
que pueden hacerlos predecibles,
y tal vez controlables.
Consideren las series temporales de precios financieros,
de una acción determinada, su acción preferida,
o un índice global.
Verán estos altibajos.
Una muy buena medida del riesgo de este mercado financiero
es la tendencia de pico a valle que representa
uno de los peores escenarios
cuando se compra en la parte superior y se vende en la parte inferior.
Se pueden ver las estadísticas, la frecuencia de la ocurrencia
del pico a valle de diferentes tamaños,
representada en este gráfico.
Ahora, curiosamente, el 99%
de los pico a valles de diferentes amplitudes
cumplen una ley universal de la energía
representada por esta línea roja.
Más interesante aún, hay comportamientos atípicos, excepciones,
que están por encima de la línea roja,
y que son por lo menos 100 veces más frecuentes,
de lo que la extrapolación predeciría
basado en una calibración del 99%
del resto de pico a valles.
Se deben a dependencias críticas
como una pérdida seguida por otra pérdida
seguida por otra, seguida por otra.
Este tipo de dependencias
se omiten en las herramientas de gestión de riesgo estándar,
que las ignoran y ven lagartos
cuando deberían ver dragones reyes.
El mecanismo raíz de un dragón rey
es una maduración lenta hacia la inestabilidad,
que es la burbuja,
y el punto culminante de la burbuja es a menudo el desplome.
Es similar al lento calentamiento del agua,
en este tubo de ensayo, para llegar al punto de ebullición,
cuando se produce inestabilidad
y se tiene la transición de fase a vapor.
Este proceso, que es absolutamente no lineal,
no se puede predecir por técnicas convencionales.
Es el reflejo de un comportamiento colectivo emergente
fundamentalmente endógeno.
La causa del desplome, la causa de la crisis,
tiene que buscarse en una inestabilidad interna del sistema.
Cualquier pequeña perturbación producirá esta inestabilidad.
Algunos de ustedes podrían pensar:
¿no está esto relacionado con el concepto del cisne negro
del que se oye hablar con frecuencia?
Recuerden, el cisne negro es este pájaro raro
que aparece repentinamente y destroza la creencia
de que todos los cisnes son blancos;
refleja la idea de imprevisibilidad,
de desconocimiento, de que los acontecimientos extremos
son fundamentalmente incognoscibles.
Nada puede ser más alejado
del concepto de dragón rey que propongo,
que es exactamente lo contrario; los fenómenos más extremos
son realmente cognoscibles y predecibles.
Así que podemos sentirnos autorizados, asumir la responsabilidad
y hacer predicciones sobre ellos.
Hagamos que mi dragón rey desaparezca el concepto del cisne negro.
(Risas)
Hay muchas señales tempranas de advertencia
que esta teoría predice.
Déjenme enfocarme en una de ellas:
el crecimiento súper exponencial con retroalimentación positiva.
¿Qué significa?
Imaginen que tienen una inversión
que el primer año produce un 5%,
el segundo año el 10%, el tercer año el 20%,
el siguiente año el 40%. ¿No es maravilloso?
Esto es un crecimiento súper exponencial.
Un crecimiento exponencial estándar sería
a una tasa de crecimiento constante, digamos, del 10%.
El punto es que, muchas veces, en las burbujas,
hay retroalimentaciones positivas que pueden
superar los crecimientos anteriores,
impulsar y aumentar el siguiente
con este tipo de crecimiento súper exponencial,
que es muy agudo y no es sostenible.
La idea clave es que la solución matemática
para esta clase de modelos presenta singularidades de tiempo finito,
lo que significa que hay un momento crítico
cuando el sistema colapsa, cambia el régimen.
Puede ser un desplome. Puede ser solo una meseta o algo diferente.
La idea clave es que el momento crítico,
la información sobre el tiempo crítico está contenida
en el desarrollo inicial del crecimiento súper exponencial.
Aplicamos esta teoría desde el principio, ese fue nuestro primer éxito,
al diagnóstico de la ruptura de elementos clave en
un cohete de acero.
Con emisión acústica, ustedes saben, ese ruidito
que emiten las estructuras. Cantan
cuando se estresan y revelan el daño.
Es un fenómeno colectivo de retroalimentación positiva;
cuanto mayor el daño, mayor el que sigue.
Entonces realmente se puede predecir,
dentro de, por supuesto, una banda de probabilidad,
cuándo se producirá la ruptura.
Esto es tan exitoso que se utiliza
en la fase inicial [no es claro] del vuelo.
Quizás más sorprendente aún, es que el mismo tipo de teoría
se puede aplicar en biología y en medicina;
en el parto, el acto de dar a luz, en las crisis epilépticas.
A los siete meses de gestación, una madre
empieza a sentir contracciones precursoras episódicas del útero;
señales de maduración
hacia la inestabilidad, para dar a luz;
el dragón rey.
Así que al medir la señal precursora,
se pueden identificar problemas pre y post-maduración,
de antemano.
Las crisis epilépticas también se dan con una gran variedad de intensidades,
y cuando el cerebro llega a un estado supercrítico,
aparecen dragones reyes con un cierto grado de previsibilidad,
lo cual puede ayudar al paciente a lidiar con la enfermedad.
Hemos aplicado esta teoría en muchos sistemas;
deslizamientos de tierra, colapsos de glaciares,
incluso en la dinámica de la predicción del éxito:
ventas de taquilla, videos de YouTube, películas, etc.
Pero quizás la más importante aplicación
es en las finanzas. Esta teoría
ilumina, en mi opinión, la razón profunda
de las crisis financieras que hemos atravesado.
Esto tiene sus raíces en 30 años de historia de burbujas,
a partir de 1980, con la burbuja global
que colapsó en 1987,
seguida por muchas otras.
La más grande fue la burbuja de la "nueva economía" de Internet
en el 2000, que colapsó ese año,
las inmobiliarias en muchos países,
las de productos financieros en todo el mundo,
burbujas bursátiles también por todas partes,
de materias primas y todas las demás, de deuda y crédito, burbujas...
burbujas, burbujas, burbujas.
Tuvimos una burbuja global.
Fue una medida de sobrevaluación global
de todos los mercados, que mostraban lo que yo llamo
la ilusión de la máquina de dinero perpetuo
que colapsó repentinamente en 2007.
El problema es que ahora estamos viendo el mismo proceso,
en particular en la política monetaria,
con la idea de una máquina de dinero perpetuo
para abordar la crisis desde el año 2008 en los EE.UU., en Europa,
en Japón.
Esto tiene implicaciones muy importantes
para entender el fracaso de la política monetaria
y de las medidas de austeridad;
mientras no ataquemos de raíz
la causa estructural de esta idea de la máquina de dinero perpetuo.
Estas son grandes afirmaciones.
¿Por qué habrían de creerme?
Bueno, tal vez porque, en los últimos 15 años
nos hemos salido de la torre de marfil,
y hemos comenzado a publicar ex ante
y subrayo el término ex ante, que significa "por adelantado",
antes de que el colapso confirme
la existencia de la burbuja o de los excesos financieros.
Estas son algunas de las grandes burbujas
que hemos sufrido en la historia reciente.
Una vez más, muchas historias interesantes para cada una de ellas.
Déjenme contarles una o dos historias
que tratan de enormes burbujas.
Todos conocemos el milagro chino.
Esta es la expresión de la enorme burbuja
en el mercado de valores; un factor de tres,
300% en pocos años.
En septiembre de 2007
fui invitado como orador a un congreso de macro
gestores de fondos de cobertura
y mostré la predicción
de que a finales de 2007, esta burbuja
cambiaría de tendencia.
Podría haber un colapso. Ciertamente no sostenible.
¿Cómo creen que los muy inteligentes,
motivados, e informados gestores de fondos
reaccionaron a esta predicción?
Habían hecho miles de millones
simplemente navegando sobre esta burbuja hasta ese momento.
Me dijeron, "Didier,
sí, el mercado podría estar sobrevaluado,
pero olvidas algo.
Vienen los Juegos Olímpicos de Beijing
en agosto de 2008 y está muy claro que
el gobierno chino está controlando la economía
y haciendo lo que se necesita
para evitar cualquier movimiento, está controlando el mercado de valores".
Tres semanas después de mi presentación,
los mercados perdieron 20%
y pasaron por una fase de volatilidad,
agitación y una pérdida total del mercado del
70% hacia finales del año.
Entonces, ¿cómo podemos estar tan colectivamente mal
por malinterpretar o hacer caso omiso de la ciencia;
del hecho de que cuando se desarrolla una inestabilidad,
y el sistema está maduro, cualquier perturbación
lo hace esencialmente incontrolable?
Se derrumbó el mercado chino, pero se recuperó.
En 2009, identificamos también que esta nueva burbuja,
una versión más pequeña, era insostenible,
así que publicamos otra vez una predicción, por adelantado,
afirmando que hacia agosto de 2009, el mercado se corregiría,
y no continuaría la tendencia.
Nuestros críticos leyeron la predicción
y dijeron, "No, no es posible.
El gobierno chino está allí.
Han aprendido su lección. Lo controlarán.
Quieren aprovechar el crecimiento".
Tal vez estos críticos no habían aprendido su lección anterior.
Entonces ocurrió la crisis. El mercado se corrigió.
Los mismos críticos dijeron: "Ah, sí,
pero publicaste tu predicción.
Influiste en el mercado.
No fue una predicción".
Tal vez entonces soy muy poderoso.
Bien, esto es interesante.
Demuestra que es esencialmente imposible hasta ahora
desarrollar la ciencia de la economía
porque somos seres conscientes que anticipamos
y existe un problema de profecías autogeneradas.
Así que hemos inventado una nueva forma de hacer ciencia.
Creamos el experimento de la burbuja financiera.
La idea es la siguiente. Vigilamos los mercados.
Identificamos los excesos, las burbujas.
Hacemos nuestro trabajo. Escribimos un informe
en el que ponemos nuestra predicción del momento crítico.
No publicamos el informe. Se mantiene secreto.
Pero con técnicas modernas de cifrado,
lo tenemos encriptado y publicamos la clave.
Seis meses después, liberamos el informe,
y hay una validación.
Todo esto se hace en un archivo internacional
para que no puedan acusarnos de liberar solo los éxitos.
Déjenme contarles de un análisis reciente.
17 de mayo de 2013, hace apenas dos semanas.
Identificamos que el mercado de valores de los Estados Unidos
iba por un camino insostenible
y publicamos en nuestro portal el 21 de mayo
que habría un cambio de tendencia.
Al día siguiente, el mercado comenzó a cambiar la tendencia, el curso.
No se trataba de un colapso.
Era solo el tercer o cuarto acto
de una enorme burbuja en ciernes.
Ampliando la discusión a nivel global,
vemos lo mismo.
Donde miremos, es observable:
en la biosfera, en la atmósfera, en el océano,
con estas trayectorias súper exponenciales
que caracterizan un camino insostenible
y anuncian una transición de fase.
El diagrama de la derecha
muestra una clara recopilación de estudios
que sugieren que en realidad hay una posibilidad no lineal
de una transición no lineal en las próximas décadas.
Es que hay burbujas en todas partes.
De un lado, esto es emocionante
para mí, como profesor que sigo las burbujas,
mata-dragones, como los medios de comunicación a veces me han llamado.
¿Pero realmente podemos matar los dragones?
Muy recientemente, con colaboradores,
estudiamos un sistema dinámico
donde el dragón rey se presenta como estos grandes lazos
y hemos podido aplicar pequeñas perturbaciones en los momentos correctos
que eliminan, cuando se tiene el control, esos dragones.
"Gouverner, c'est prévoir".
Gobernar es el arte de la planificación y la predicción.
Pero, ¿probablemente no es este el caso de
una de las lagunas más grandes de la humanidad,
que tiene la responsabilidad de dirigir
nuestras sociedades y nuestro planeta hacia la sostenibilidad
ante crisis y desafíos crecientes?
Pero la teoría del dragón rey da esperanza.
Hemos aprendido que la mayoría de los sistemas tienen algo de previsibilidad.
Es posible desarrollar diagnósticos anticipados de las crisis
para estar preparados, para poder tomar medidas,
para asumir la responsabilidad,
y que nunca nos vuelvan a tomar otra vez
por sorpresa los extremos ni las crisis como en la gran recesión
o en la crisis europea.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)